abocados al colapso económico afganistán
está sumido en una grave crisis derivada
de la toma del poder del grupo talibán
dos meses después el régimen de los
fundamentalistas lanzó un programa para
combatir el hambre ofreciendo a miles de
personas trigo a cambio de mano de obra
este programa es para la prevención de
la crisis alimentaria la pobreza y el
hambre
el plan para luchar contra el desempleo
y la pobreza se extenderá a lo largo del
país empleando a unos 40 mil hombres
sólo en la capital kabul los ciudadanos
sufren constantes cortes de electricidad
las secuelas de la sequía y un sistema
económico fallido ante la llegada del
frío invierno los talibanes buscan
soluciones
estamos intentando sacar a nuestra gente
de la situación actual y ayudarles
económicamente también ha llegado la
ayuda mundial intentamos organizar y
distribuir la ayuda incluyendo alimento
y ropa todas las preocupaciones se
resolverán
desde su ascenso al poder la comunidad
internacional suspendió la ayuda al
desarrollo de las que dependían millones
de familias afganas que sobreviven
resignados bajo el yugo talibán
y
se han cerrado las fronteras por lo que
las importaciones y exportaciones no
están permitidas es difícil para la
gente satisfacer sus necesidades básicas
porque la mayoría de las personas que
trabajan en el gobierno no reciben
salario la moneda afgana también ha
perdido su valor como acorde con
esperamos nador al país o bandas dólar
short valorada según naciones unidas 18
millones de personas precisan ayuda
humanitaria con el 97 por ciento en
riesgo de hundirse en la pobreza en 2022
si no se toman medidas urgentes